my so-called friends slash handlers  around me told me like if I said that I  like Trump that my career will be over  that my life would be over uh they said  stuff like people get killed for wearing  a hat like that they threaten my life  they put my life they basically said  that I would be killed  uh for uh  wearing the Hat I had uh someone called  me last night and said anybody wearing a  white lives matter shirt is going to be  green lit and that means that they're  going to beat them up if they wear it  I'm like you know okay green like me  then subscribe to the Fox News YouTube  channel to catch our nightly opens  stories that are changing the world and  changing your life from Tucker Carlson  tonight